this episode of the y-files is brought
to you by Factor
here's the scene you're driving down a
secluded Road the only lights come from
your headlights the only sounds you hear
are crickets and the hum of the engine
suddenly a mysterious orb of light
appears in the distance floating a few
feet above the ground you get the sense
that the light is aware of your presence
it darts around beckoning you closer it
can't be another car there is nothing
around for Miles now as you get closer
to the light it vanishes finally you
arrive at a small town and stop at a
diner for a bite you mention your
experience to the waitress she smiles
and says you saw a ghost light she tells
you the story of someone killed on that
dark Road many years ago the light has
been seen ever since ghost lights or
spook lights are seen all over the world
in some places they're thought to be the
spirits of the Dead other places say
their portals to another dimension and
others say their signals from another
world whatever they are ghost lights are
real and they've stumped scientists
Skeptics even governments for a long
time they're seen by thousands of people
every year there are even cases where
people have followed a ghost light into
the darkness never to be seen again
foreign
this isn't fistable at all
I need you to send over the recipe for
the dish you made last week I mean the
whole shebang shopping lists
measurements cooking times all of it
stat now yesterday coach sweet whoa slow
down what's going on well I'm a
contestant on countdown kitchen the
winner gets their own cooking show I
thought I had this thing in a bag but
the judges just disqualified my recipe
for crab cat cakes apparently crabs are
fine but they were very suspicious about
cats I can't imagine why if I lose this
contest then I grew this bike blood here
goatee and double chin for nothing yeah
well maybe you should probably only have
15 minutes to give him a new recipe
I don't even know what recipe you're
talking about that creamy chicken cheesy
tasty chicken cheesy made two days ago
it was it was it was divine okay okay
okay calm down that wasn't my recipe
that was factor
is that today's sponsor
yes it is factor is a subscription meal
service that delivers pre-prepared meals
to your door they're fresh never Frozen
and ready to heat and eat in minutes
yeah but that meal was delicious it
didn't taste like microwave food well
that's because Factor has registered
dietitians working with Gourmet chefs to
do all the planning cooking and prep for
you yeah but what about variety that is
the uh despite life
they upload new menus every week with
over 27 meals and 33 add-on options they
have plans that range from 4 to 18 meals
a week and you can add or reduce at any
time well I use them here at the studio
they have meat plant-based meals seafood
seafood sorry and factor is now owned by
hellofresh so I just switched between
the two Brands both convenient and easy
let me do some math here 18 meals at
times 16 weeks I carried 11 in there
carry the 11. that'll do it do what get
me through the funnels on countdown
kitchen
wait did you just say you're gonna be
gone 16 weeks
okay
head to factor75.com or click the link
below and use code the Y files 50 to get
50 off your first Factor box back to
75.com would code the wide files 50 and
I get 50 off my first box that's right
okay I'm definitely gonna get my own
cooking show now I just need a
catchphrase catchphrase it's like a
slogan I know what it is oh out how
about let's go to flavor Town that's
taken you should probably just focus on
oh how about this fish is funky that
might not be exactly
where I gotta go
on December 4th 1931 a trail of blood
almost a quarter of a mile long was
found in the small town of gurden
Arkansas it led to the body of will
McLean
a railroad spike hammer and a shovel
covered in blood were found near his
body it was clear that the cause of
death was four severe blows to the head
but there was one detail of the murder
that would haunt the town forever
McLean's Lantern was still clutched
tightly in his hand
shortly after will McLean's death people
started reporting seeing a strange light
the light was appearing along a Four
Mile Stretch of railroad track near the
town it was described as yellowish white
and moved like someone searching the
tracks with Lantern and researchers have
been trying for years to explain the
garden light obviously aliens
the popular theory is that people are
seeing headlights from interstate 30.
now this makes sense at first I-30 is
only a couple of miles away from the
train tracks close enough to trick the
Mind into thinking those headlights are
floating orbs but there is a problem
with this explanation people started
reporting the light in 1931 Interstate
30 wasn't built until the late 1960s the
light starts coming on and going off
coming on and going off
and it went off when it got about 10
feet from us
the next time we saw the light it was
behind us another theory is that the
light is swamp gas gurden Railway is
surrounded by dense woods and swamps
oh
swamp gas happens in marshlands and bogs
when gases from decomposing organic
matter combust
ERS like mother nature lighting her foot
that's tacky but accurate
but the gurney light has been seen in
all kinds of weather including on windy
nights and wind prevents swamp gas from
igniting it floats about that half off
the ground follow
it's a light white ball of light about
like that though many people have seen
and photographed the garden light it's
hard to find you have to walk on
railroad tracks in the dark a few miles
from the nearest road or town now even
if you take that dangerous walk there's
only a small chance that you'll see the
light
but there's a town that has so many
ghost light sightings that they actually
built a large observation deck the
lights there have been featured on
countless TV shows they've been in
movies they've inspired songs if you
want to see some of the most spectacular
ghost lights in the world you have to go
to West Texas
[Music]
in 1883 Robert Reed Ellison was working
on a ranch just outside the newly
founded town of Marfa Texas one night he
saw a distant light that he thought
could be from an Apache campfire or from
another Rancher but there was something
about the light that was strange he
tossed and turned all night unable to
shake the odd feeling that the light
whatever it was was aware of him the
next morning Reed went out to explore
the area and found no sign of people
soon after Ellison learned an Apache
legend about the land many years ago a
great battle took place between two
warring tribes the conflict was brutal
and the death toll was in the thousands
the legend says that the Marvel lights
we see today are the spirits of restless
Warriors still wandering the desert
trying to find a way back home
the lights are described as glowing
basketball-sized spheres they hover
about shoulder height off the ground and
have been known to shoot around rapidly
in any direction they appear in pairs or
in groups but sometimes single lights
divide into pairs they've been seen
merging disappearing and then
reappearing and sometimes they seem to
move in regular patterns like there's an
intelligence at work if you're a mystery
and I want them to remain a Ministry
many towns known for Paranormal Activity
don't advertise it but like Point
Pleasant West Virginia has embraced the
Mothman Marva has embraced the Marfa
lights
in 2003 the town built a marfolights
viewing Center there's even a Marvel
Lights Festival held each September on
Labor Day weekend there's a street
parade food and live music but not all
ghost light experiences are so positive
in fact some are downright terrifying
[Music]
surency is a small town in Georgia
located about 90 miles Southwest of
Savannah and that's where you'll find
the CERN sea lights which are bright
yellow or white orbs of light unlike the
garden lights these also appear near
train tracks again we with the train
tracks
well seeing lights near train tracks is
pretty common and there are a couple of
theories for this one is that the lights
are ghosts of dead workers in the 19th
century working on a railroad required
fearlessness and a little bit of
recklessness Railway workers had long
shifts and the work was physically
demanding and dangerous in the early
days of the railroad one out of 35
workers were injured every year and in
many cases the injuries resulted in
missing Limbs and almost one out of
every 100 workers died on the job maybe
the light scene around the tracks are
spirits haunting their place of death
another theory for lights around train
tracks is that the tracks are liminal
spaces
a liminal space is a threshold Between
Two Worlds existing in neither world and
both at the same time hello
hello
it's a place of transition of waiting
and not knowing what's just beyond that
door or right around that corner or just
a little further down the tracks and
some believe that liminal spaces can act
as portals to other dimensions including
the spirit world the CERN sea lines are
often considered to be spirits of the
dead because the town's dark history
the town of surency gets its name from
its founder Alan Powell surrency in 1852
he built a two-story home for his family
on land next to the train tracks for the
first 20 years things were pretty normal
but then things went from normal to not
normal
one evening cerency's daughter
Clementine was waiting by the train
tracks for her father to come home and
as the sun set she noticed a dark figure
approaching with an uneasy feeling she
headed back home as she reached her
house she felt a stone land near her
when she turned to look where the object
was thrown from the dark figure was gone
she quickly went inside where several of
her father's friends were gathered it
wasn't long before everyone heard what
Clementine experienced outside heavy
items were falling all over the property
when Clementine walked into the kitchen
small pieces of brick rained down
everywhere when her father's friends
came into the kitchen to see what was
happening they saw pots and pans jumping
around and knives sliding around the
floor Alan sorensy finally got home and
saw the damage at first he thought
there'd been an earthquake but nobody
felt a Tremor and none of his neighbors
were affected then things escalated soon
the entire family witnessed furniture
and objects moving on their own pictures
fell from walls plates cups books and
Bottles shot from their shelves with
violent Force Allen wrote down what he
witnessed and sent a telegraph to the
Savannah Morning News who published it a
week later
a few minutes of my arrival at home I
saw the glass tumblers begin to slide
off the slab and the Crockery to fall
upon the floor and break the books began
to Tumble from their shelves to the
floor while brick bats billets of wood
smoothing irons biscuits potatoes tiny
pans water buckets pitchers Etc began to
fall in different parts of my house
nearly all of my Crockery and glasses
have been broken there have been many
other strange occurrences about my house
these facts can be established by 75 or
a hundred Witnesses
the paper sent out an experienced
reporter to verify the story the
reporter couldn't believe it
clocks in the home were going haywire
they were spinning rapidly forward and
backward in time a mirror exploded into
a rain of glass and strange noises were
heard all over the house like footsteps
and banging at night you can hear
disembodied voices laughter and
sometimes screaming from empty rooms
Allen was a leader of the community and
tried to take this all in stride but
then the house started targeting his
daughter some unseen force would yank
her covers off of her at night and pull
her hair and sometimes throw her across
the room at that point Alan called it
quits and the family moved out
five years later Alan psurancey passed
away and The Haunting stopped shortly
after Allen's death orbs of light were
seen hovering over the train tracks near
his home all certainty residents know
the story of the Cerny house haunting
and the CERN sea lights and while the
story is spooky they'll tell you that
the lights are harmless
but that isn't always the case some
ghost lights are very very dangerous
worldwide millions of people go missing
every year some get lost and can't find
their way back home others run away and
don't want to be found but there are
plenty of missing persons cases that
can't be explained in Australia almost
40 000 people are reported missing every
year that's one person every 18 minutes
that just vanishes and more than a few
of these disappearances have been blamed
on the minmin lights
got it
the min-min lights get their name from
the now abandoned settlement of minmin
which is about 70 miles from bulya and
boulia is in a remote western region of
Queensland about a thousand miles
Northwest of Brisbane stories about the
lights predate the European colonization
of Australia and some Aboriginal people
believe the minmin lights are the
spirits of their elders
and before the town was destroyed by a
fire it was known for being a watering
hole among the buildings burned to the
ground was the minmin hotel which had a
graveyard at back now a hotel with a
graveyard at back might seem surprising
but Midland wasn't your average hotel in
1947 a daily newspaper described it
in the old rough days the hotel at
minmin was famed for its wildiness and
its gut-rotting drinks many Ashira with
a big check drank himself to death at
the infamous hotel or was killed in a
drunken brawl or was murdered for his
money the corpses were tossed into the
backyard
it sounds like every Hotel in Portland
these days
the first popular report of amendment
light sighting was in 1918 and The Story
Goes Like This
around midnight a farmer shows up at the
Boolean police station in hysterics he's
going on about being chased by a strange
light as he was riding past the midman
hotel's abandoned Cemetery he saw an orb
of light appear right above a grave the
light hovered for a few seconds the
farmer had the Eerie feeling that the
light was aware of him then suddenly the
light shot right at the farmer he
panicked jumped on his horse and started
riding as fast as he could
foreign
shoulder the light was following him no
matter how fast he rode the light kept
up it finally disappeared when he got
into town since that night there have
been countless sightings of the minmin
lights and there's one thing that almost
everyone says after being confronted
with the min-min light the puzzling
thing is that so many people say that it
seems to have a mind of its own
it follows them or it goes away from
them
now if this is so it could be a psychic
phenomenon
all I know is that there is something
there which needs to be explained the
light seems to have intelligence and
it's not friendly
I couldn't say for one minute what it is
but it's got to be nothing alive because
I've
said to me you you on a driver say that
he can ride up and see it here then
within a few seconds it's behind him
somewhere else sometimes the light will
chase Witnesses other times it tries to
get people to follow it it was
terrifying because the light to see it
coming towards you it used to come up
came up it came up close and if you if
you went towards it well it just dance
away from there according to the legend
anyone who follows the lights disappears
and is never seen again newspaper
columnist Bilbo Yang found this out
firsthand
one night bill was camping in the
outback with some friends when a strange
light appeared
we were all sitting looking into the
darkness well away from the dying
campfire and enjoying the cool air after
the heat of the day when suddenly I saw
a light at first I thought it was
someone waving a lantern but it suddenly
Rose higher in the air danced a few Jigs
and hovered about first high and then
low but always keeping at about 50 yards
distant
it was clear that whatever was
controlling the light was not a person
it looked like a huge ball of glowing
Embers bill was intrigued and urged his
group to go after it but the men in the
group knew the story about the minmin
lights and they knew that no matter what
if you see one you don't follow it Bill
wasn't impressed he got up and went off
to find who or what was behind this
mysterious light
Bill walked slowly through the darkness
brush and twigs snapping beneath his
feet the light hovered in place and Bill
could swear it was waiting for him
finally bill was far away from camp and
the light was only a few yards ahead of
him then suddenly the light bounced in
the air emitted a Flash and shot down
into the ground Bill took another step
when he heard panicked voices yelling at
him from Camp he turned around and he
could see his friends by firelight
waving their arms and shouting for him
to stop moving Bill Frozen place
the light then floated up still a few
yards ahead it hovered about shoulder
height waited for a second or two and
then shot back down through the ground
but then Bill noticed something the
light wasn't shooting through the ground
it was diving into a deep Chasm that
went down hundreds of feet
Bill looked down and saw he was one
Maybe Two Steps From The Cliff if he
kept following the light it would have
fallen to his death the light then
traveled back to him a couple of times
and Bill felt like it wanted him to
follow when bill turned and headed back
to Camp the light disappeared James
Burch from the nearby town of Kimberly
had a midman light sighting while
driving home from a hunting trip
it was with a few friends when the light
appeared in the distance they were all
Struck By the Light and like many other
Witnesses said they felt like it was
aware of them suddenly they weren't
driving toward Town anymore they were
now following the strange light through
the bush in the complete opposite
direction nobody remembered turning
around but there they were following
this light into the darkness mesmerized
they stopped the car gathered themselves
and the light disappeared ooh missing
time and it doesn't sound like ghosts no
it doesn't and like the Apache in Texas
the local tribes claimed the minimum
lights are wandering spirits but there
are some people who believe they're from
some place farther away well how much
farther away can you get in heaven well
wait
[Music]
ghostlights or spook lights are seen all
over the world some places have become
famous for them Marfa Texas gurgen
Arkansas Cerny Georgia they're also the
Brown Mountain Lights in North Carolina
and the Joplin spook light on the border
of Missouri in Oklahoma it's a long list
but can these be explained by science
well sometimes ghost lights are usually
attributed to one of a few natural
phenomena one is swamp gas which is
Mother Nature lighting her farts that's
enough
decaying organic matter is flammable and
under certain conditions it can ignite
now it's possible that some ghost lights
are swamp gas but in places where lights
appear during different weather
conditions it's not swamp gas another
explanation is piezoelectric effect and
when quartz crystals are placed under
stress like from tectonic activity they
can produce an enormous amount of
electricity gurden Georgia sits on top
of a large quartz deposit and is on a
fault line plus an earthquake was felt
about the same time will McLean was
murdered on the train tracks
but this doesn't explain why the light
appears as a ball and hovers or why it
appears frequently even when there's no
seismic activity
another explanation for ghost lights is
when certain atmospheric conditions
create optical illusions
there's a phenomenon called a superior
Mirage which occurs when the air near
the ground is colder than the air above
it this bends light rays so that objects
look like they're floating above the
surface a superior Mirage is pretty rare
but the best place to see one is where
you can view a long distance unobscured
like over large bodies of water or over
a large swath of flat terrain terrain
for example that you can find in Marfa
Texas
it had long been suspected that the
Marvel Alliance are actually car
headlights coming from Highway 67 and
Highway 90 in the area well in 2004 a
group of physics students went to Marfa
to try to solve this over a three-day
period they found that the number of
Marfa lights directly correlated to the
amount of traffic on Highway 67. to
further prove their point they sent the
car out to the highway and had it flash
its lights they were able to generate a
marvelite every single time
well that's true Robert Reed Ellison
said he spotted the lights in 1883 right
right except he didn't oh there was no
record of him ever saying it he even
published Memoirs of his life in 1937
and it didn't come up the story comes
from his daughter Julia and they thought
they were probably a campfire Indians or
other Travelers but they just kept
seeing them the next night they were
there and the next night and the next
week and year and I'm sure they began to
wonder what on Earth were those lights
now to be fair the lights do merge and
spread apart and disappear and reappear
this could still be light bending in
different ways but it would be unusual
for a superior Mirage to behave this way
now most Marfa lights are definitely
headlights but locals swear that you can
still see the lights when looking in the
direction away from the highways and you
don't argue with Texans
the currency light is a tricky one in
1985 scientists did discover a pocket of
liquid nine miles below the surface in
the area now this doesn't directly
explain the light but it is something
strange
the truth is most of the ghost lights
around the world can be explained but
not all of them the lights in the
histalen valley are the strangest of all
Daniel gross outlines the technology and
methods that could be used to create the
exact phenomenon we see in Hess Stalin
that there is an Alien Probe high in the
Earth's orbit sending laser pulses into
the atmosphere his theory could explain
all the lights we're seeing around the
world now the paper is highly technical
but its hypothesis is the only
explanation that answers every question
and solves every puzzle associated with
ghost lights ten years ago a theory
about an Alien Probe firing burst of
energy into our atmosphere seemed
improbable but not impossible when you
eliminate the impossible then whatever
remains however improbable must be the
truth
right with whistleblowers coming forward
and Congress demanding answers Dr Gross
and his improbable Galactic neighborhood
Theory could be the answer and it may
turn out that the truth is out there
after all
thank you so much for hanging out with
me today my name is AJ that cycle fish
this has been the Y files if you had fun
or learned anything do us a favor like
subscribe comment share that stuff
really helps the channel and like every
topic we cover here on the channel
today's was recommended by you so if
there's a story you'd like to see or
learn more about go to the yfiles.com
tips and if you need more wi files in
your life because who doesn't check out
the y-files Discord it's free to join
there's thousands of people on there and
they're on there 24 7. and special
thanks to our patrons who make the whole
Channel possible every episode is
dedicated to you and I can't thank you
enough for your generosity and if you'd
like to support the channel consider
becoming a member on patreon for as
little as three dollars a month you keep
the white files going get early access
to videos without commercials Early
Access to fun products like the talking
hecklefish plushie t-shirts just for
patreon members and two extra live
streams a week just for you another
great way to support is grab something
from the Wi-Fi store
[Music]
that's gonna do it until next time be
safe be kind and know that you are
appreciated
[Music]
51 a secret code inside the Bible said I
was
I love my UFOs and paranormal buns as
well as music songs
[Music]
but then another conspiracy theory
becomes the truth my friends and it
never ends
[Music]
to aware
did Stanley Kubrick fake the moon
landing alone
[Music]
and his name was cold
with the
on Thursday next Wednesday days
[Music]
I can't believe
after
[Music]
it is
dance with the feeling is
[Music]
foreign